ओके अगर मैं आपसे पूछता हूं कि आप एक पेपर
एक कागज़ का टुकड़ा लो तो आप उसे कितनी
बार फोल्ड कर सकते हो और यह कागज़ एक
नॉर्मल पतला कागज़ है जो कि एक नॉर्मल बुक
के पेज में होता है अब आप में से कई लोग
बोलेंगे कि सर मैं इसे चार बार फोल्ड कर
सकता हूं कई लोग बोलेंगे मैं इसे पांच बार
फोल्ड कर सकता हूं और जो लोग हम में से
जिम वगैरह जाते हैं वह शायद बोलेंगे कि
मैं इसे आठ बार फोल्ड कर सकता हूं लेकिन
अगर इस पेपर को कोई 45 बार फोल्ड कर दे तो
क्या होगा आप में से कई लोग हसेंगे और
बोलेंगे कि कोई भी एक पेपर को 45 टाइम्स
फोल्ड नहीं कर सकता चार या पांच फोल्ड्स
के बाद यह बहुत डिफिकल्ट हो जाता है लेकिन
सवाल यह नहीं है आप मान लीजिए कि एक पेपर
बड़ा है न्यूज़पेपर जितना या उससे भी बड़ा
पेपर है तो जब हम इस पेपर को फोल्ड करेंगे
तो यह पेपर कितना थिक हो जाएगा क्या यह
आपके मोबाइल की विड्थ जितना थिक हो जाएगा
या यह आपकी हाइट जितना थिक हो जाएगा या
आपके घर की बिल्डिंग की हाइट जितना थिक हो
जाएगा या फिर कोई बात नहीं आप इस वीडियो
को पॉज कर सकते हैं और आप गेस कर सकते हैं
कि इसकी थिकनेस कितनी हो जाएगी आई होप
आपने गेस कर लिया होगा अगर मैं आपको बोलूं
कि ये दुनिया की सबसे बड़ी बिल्डिंग बुर्ज
खलीफा से भी बहुत ज्यादा थिक हो जाएगा तो
आप क्या सोचोगे आप बोलोगे ऐसा तो हो ही
नहीं सकता लेकिन अगर रियलिटी बताऊं तो अगर
आप एक पेपर को 45 टाइम्स फोल्ड कर देते हो
तो आप अर्थ से लेके मून तक के डिस्टेंस को
कवर कर लोगे यानी ये पेपर इतना ज्यादा थिक
हो जाएगा और अगर आप इसे एक और बार फोल्ड
करते हो यानी 46 टाइम फोल्ड करते हो तो ये
पेपर इतना थिक हो जाएगा कि आप अर्थ से मून
और मून से वापस अर्थ भी भी पहुंच सकते हो
आई नो ये बहुत डिफिकल्ट हो रहा होगा
इमेजिन करने के लिए और इससे पहले कि मैं
कंपाउंडिंग के कांसेप्ट को और डिटेल में
एक्सप्लेन करूं इस एग्जांपल को हम थोड़ी
सी सिंपल भाषा में कैलकुलेशंस करके देखते
हैं कि जो मैंने बोला है वह ठीक भी है या
नहीं देखो एक पेपर की थिकनेस ऑलमोस्ट होती
है 0.001 सेमी अब अगर हम इस पेपर को पहली
बार फोल्ड करते हैं तो उसकी थिकनेस हो
जाएगी 0.002 सेमी एक और बार फोल्ड करते
हैं तो उसकी थिकनेस होगी 0.004 सेमी एक और
बार करते हैं तो 0.008 सेमी एक और बार
करते हैं तो 0.016 सेमी एंड सो ऑन लेकिन
अगर इसे हम 10th टाइम फोल्ड करते हैं तो
इसकी थिकनेस हो जाएगी 1.02 4 सेमी 20th
टाइम फोल्ड करते हैं तो यह 1048 सेमी हो
चुका होगा यानी 34 फीट के आसपास जिसका
मतलब है कि एप्रोक्सीमेटली 3 फ्लोर की
बिल्डिंग जितना थिक 45th टाइम अगर इसे हम
फोल्ड करते हैं तो यह 35 लाख किमी थिक हो
गया होगा यानी जितना डिस्टेंस अर्थ से
लेकर मून तक का है और अगर आप बस इसे एक और
बार फोल्ड कर दो तो यह 7 लाख किमी के
आसपास हो जाएगा यानी हम अर्थ से मून और
वापस मून से अर्थ भी आ सकते हैं
कंपाउंडिंग के इफेक्ट को एक और
इंटरेस्टिंग एग्जांपल से समझा जा सकता है
मान लीजिए आप सुबह 8:00 बजे एक एमटी टेस्ट
ट्यूब लेते हैं और उसमें पांच-छह
पेनिसिलिन के बैक्टीरिया डाल देते हैं और
मान लीजिए कि हर एक बैक्टीरिया खुद को हर
एक सेकंड में डबल कर सकता है अगर आपको पता
है कि दिन में 12:00 बजे यह टेस्ट ट्यूब
फुल हो जाती है तो सवाल यह है कि टेस्ट
ट्यूब आधी कब थी आप में से जो लोग
इंटेलिजेंट हैं वह समझते हैं कि 12:00
बजने से जस्ट 1 सेकंड पहले यह टेस्ट ट्यूब
हाफ थी क्योंकि बैक्टीरिया खुद को हर
सेकंड में डबल जो कर रहा है लेकिन जस्ट
इमेजिन कि 12 बजने से सिर्फ छ या 7 सेकंड
पहले क्या हुआ होगा अगर कोई उस वक्त टेस्ट
ट्यूब को देख रहा होगा तो वह ऑलमोस्ट खाली
लग रही होगी क्योंकि उसमें बहुत ही कम
बैक्टीरिया दिख रहे होंगे और हम सोचेंगे
कि हां यार सब ठीक है अभी तो पता नहीं
कितना टाइम लगेगा इस पूरी टेस्ट ट्यूब को
भरने में क्योंकि पिछले तीन या चार घंटे
में यह सिर्फ टेस्ट ट्यूब इतनी सी ही भरी
है लेकिन सिर्फ पांच या सेकंड्स के बाद
क्या होगा जस्ट लाइक मैजिक यह टेस्ट ट्यूब
पूरी भर गई होगी और यह पार है एक्सपो शियल
ग्रोथ की कंपाउंडिंग की नेक्स्ट हम बात
करते हैं मैक्सिमम लोगों का मोस्ट
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक कंपाउंडिंग ऑफ मनी मान
लीजिए 1 साल में दो बच्चे पैदा हुए एक थे
आप और एक आपका बेस्ट फ्रेंड आपके फ्रेंड
के और आपके पेरेंट्स दोनों लॉन्ग विजन
रखते हैं और पैसे की इंपॉर्टेंस को समझते
हैं इसलिए आपके पैदा होने पर आप आपके
रिश्तेदारों ने जितने भी आपके लिए गिफ्ट
दिए थे या पैसे दिए थे उन सब पैसों को
इकट्ठा करके आपके पेरेंट्स ने उन्हें
बेचकर आपके लिए ₹1 लाख जमा कर दिए थे एफडी
में 15 पर सिंपल इंटरेस्ट रेट पे वहां पर
आपके फ्रेंड के पेरेंट्स ने भी अपने बच्चे
के पैदा होते ही ₹1 लाख निफ्टी इंडेक्स
फंड्स में डाल दिए जहां पर उन्हें भी ऑन
एन एवरेज 15 पर का रेट ऑफ रिटर्न ही मिल
रहा था लेकिन यह कंपाउंडेड होना था दोनों
पेरेंट्स का गोल यह था कि बच्चों को तो
पेंशन नहीं मिलेगी क्योंकि गवर्नमेंट
स्कीम्स ही ऐसी ला रही है इसीलिए पैसे आप
लोगों के रिटायरमेंट में काम आएंगे यस वो
इतने लॉन्ग विजनस थे कि उन्होंने अपनी
रिटायरमेंट नहीं बल्कि आपकी रिटायरमेंट का
भी सोच लिया जब आप पैदा हुए थे अब आप और
आपका फ्रेंड बड़े होते हैं अच्छी एजुकेशन
लेते हैं जॉब लेते हैं और वो दिन आ जाता
है जब आपकी रिटायरमेंट होती है आप दोनों
अब 58 इयर्स के हो चुके हो आप दोनों के
पेरेंट्स भी आपके साथ हैं थोड़े बुजुर्ग
हो गए हैं लेकिन अभी भी आपको वो उतना ही
प्यार करते हैं जितना कि बचपन में करते थे
वो आप दोनों को बताते हैं कि आप लोगों के
लिए उन्होंने बचपन से ही पैसे जोड़े थे जो
आप आज विड्रॉ कर सकते हैं आप बैंक में
देखते हैं और आपको पता चलता है कि 15 पर
सिंपल इंटरेस्ट के हिसाब से वो पैसे 99.7
टाइम्स हो गए हैं यानी
9700 ओबवियसली आप खुश होते हैं कि पैदा
होते ही बचपन में जो आपको गिफ्ट मिले थे
उनसे तो आपने वैसे ही नहीं खेल पाना था
इससे बेटर तो यह है कि यह ₹ लाख आपके काम
तो आएंगे इसके बाद आपका फ्रेंड अपना
अमाउंट देखता है जो कि 15 पर से हर साल क
फाउंड हो रहा था और उसके ₹1 लाख 33 करोड़
9388 हो चुके हैं अब ज्यादा इमोशनल होने
की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि ये एग्जांपल
मैंने इसलिए लिया था ताकि टाइमलाइन ज्यादा
करके कंपाउंडिंग की पार को दिखाया जा सके
कहां 10 लाख और कहां ₹ करोड़ इन्वेस्टमेंट
अमाउंट भी सेम इन्वेस्टमेंट टाइम भी सेम
इवन की इन्वेस्टमेंट परसेंटेज भी सेम
दोस्तों अगर आप लॉन्ग विजन रखते हैं और
इन्वेस्टमेंट में इंटरेस्टेड हैं तो आप
डिस्क्रिप्शन पर दिए लिंक से या फर्स्ट
कमेंट के लिंक से से अप स्टॉ की ऐप
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं उस लिंक से आप अपना
फ्री डी मैट अकाउंट बना सकते हैं और शुरू
में बहुत ही कम पैसे इन्वेस्ट करके
इन्वेस्टमेंट स्ट्रेटेजी ट्राई कर सकते
हैं मेरी रेकमेंडेड में हम सिर्फ निफ्टी
50 से ही ट्राई करें नेक्स्ट पॉइंट कहता
है कंपाउंडिंग इन हेल्थ जस्ट इमेजिन तीन
दोस्त हैं राम श्याम और राहुल तीनों
आइडेंट वेट भी आइडेंट कल ईटिंग हैबिट्स भी
आइडेंट इवन एक्सरसाइज हैबिट्स भी आइडेंट
इन तीनों का वेट भी एगजैक्टली सेम है 75
केजी इन तीनों को हर शाम खाना खाने के बाद
एक आदत है ये सब एक चॉकलेट जरूर खाते हैं
अब इनकी ईटिंग हैबिट्स में सिर्फ एक चेंज
आता है राहुल शाम को एक्स्ट्रा चॉकलेट
खाना शुरू कर देता है राम रात को चॉकलेट
खाना बंद कर देता है और शाम अपने में कोई
चेंज नहीं लाता अब 3 सालों के बाद राहुल
जो कि एक एक्स्ट्रा चॉकलेट हर रोज खा रहा
था उसका वेट 93 केज हो जाता है जबकि शाम
का सेम वेट ही रहेगा और राम का वेट 75
केजी से 57 केजी के आसपास हो जाता है
ओबवियसली हर रोज इस एक एक्स्ट्रा चॉकलेट
से राहुल ने 17.7 केजी का वेट गेन कर लिया
जो कि फाइनली लीड कर सकता है हाई
कोलेस्ट्रॉल लेवल फ्रस्ट्रेशन और बाकी
बीमारियों को पॉइंट यह है कि एक छोटा सा
चेंज लंबे समय में एक कंपाउंड इफेक्ट
क्रिएट कर सकता है नेक्स्ट पॉइंट आता है
कंपाउंडिंग एंड नॉलेज वॉरेन बफेट बोलते
हैं कि हर रोज कुछ ना कुछ टाइम इन्वेस्ट
करो नॉलेज में ऐसे ही नॉलेज बिल्ड होती है
और हमें कंपाउंड इंटरेस्ट देती रहती है
क्या आपको पता है कि जब इलन मस्क यंग थे
और अपनी इनिशियल कंपनी
[संगीत]
[हंसी]
एक साल में 15 से 18 बुक्स कंप्लीट कर
सकते हो व्हिच इज आउटस्टैंडिंग वो कहते
हैं ना कि जो इंसान बुक्स नहीं पढ़ता उसका
ब्रेन भी उतना ही रह जाता है जो बेचारा
पढ़ ही नहीं सकता तो पॉइंट इज स्पेंड
एटलीस्ट 15 टू 20 मिनट्स अ डे फॉर योर
नॉलेज बिकॉज इन्वेस्टमेंट एंड नॉलेज पेज द
हाईएस्ट इंटरेस्ट तो एक बार अगर हम सारे
पॉइंट्स को एक साथ देखें तो शुरू में हमने
सबसे पहले देखा था कि एक पेपर को अगर हम
45 टाइम्स फोल्ड कर देते हैं तो उसकी
थिकनेस इतनी हो जाएगी कि वो अर्थ से मून
तक का डिस्टेंस कवर कर सकती है एक और बार
यानी 46 टाइम अगर हम इसी पेपर को फोल्ड
करते हैं तो यह मून से वापस हमें अर्थ तक
भी पहुंचा देगी फिर हमने पेनिसिलिन
बैक्टीरिया की बात की थी अगर उनकी ग्रोथ
भी कंपाउंड हो रही है तो कैसे 5 सेकंड्स
में बैक्टीरिया ऑलमोस्ट खाली टेस्ट ट्यूब
से पूरी टेस्ट ट्यूब में भर सकता है जिससे
हमें कोरोना वायरस की ओबवियसली याद आ जाती
है इसके बाद हमने देखा था कि कैसे 58
इयर्स में 15 पर सिंपल इंटरेस्ट 1 लाख को
10 लाख के करीब पहुंचा देता है लेकिन वहीं
पर कंपाउंड इंटरेस्ट 1 लाख को 33 करोड़ के
आसपास बना देता है उसके बाद हमने कंपाउंड
इफेक्ट हेल्थ में देखा था कि कैसे 125
कैलोरी की एक चॉकलेट खाने से 3 साल में
कैसे किसी का वेट 17 केजी तक बढ़ सकता है
जिससे ऑब् वियस आगे कूमेट इफेक्ट हो जाता
है और फाइनली हमने देखा था कि हर रोज
सिर्फ 15 से 20 मिनट अगर हम अपनी नॉलेज को
स्पेंड करते हैं तो हम साल की 10 से 15
बुक्स कंप्लीट कर सकते हैं अगर हम पढ़ना
नहीं चाहते तो हम कम से कम ऑडियो सुन सकते
हैं जब हम कोई अनप्रिटेंशस
दोस्तों अगर आप कंपाउंडिंग के प्रिंसिपल
को अपनी लाइफ में इंप्लीमेंट करना चाहते
हैं तो जस्ट स्पेंड 15 टू 20 मिनट्स जब भी
आप फ्री हो वॉकिंग कर रहे हो जम कर रहे हो
या कोई भी वॉशरूम में क्यों ना हो लिसन टू
वन ग्रेट आइडिया जो आपको सक्सेस की तरफ ले
जाएगा शुरू के 20-30 दिन तो लगेगा कि कुछ
नहीं हो रहा लेकिन फिर एक्सपो एंजियल
ग्रोथ स्टार्ट होगी तो अगर आप अपनी नॉलेज
में टाइम इन्वेस्ट करना चाहते हैं तो आप ग
ए डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं जहां पर हिंदी में
फ्री में 130 से ज्यादा बुक सरीज अवेलेबल
हैं जिन्हें आप पढ़ भी सकते हैं और सुन भी
सकते हैं अगर आप अपनी नॉलेज में
कंपाउंडिंग चाहते हैं तो इस एप्लीकेशन का
लिंक हम डिस्क्रिप्शन और फर्स्ट कमेंट में
दे देंगे दोस्तों अगर आपको लगता है कि
आपके किसी फ्रेंड या फैमिली मेंबर की यह
वीडियो काम आ सकती हैं तो यह वीडियो आप
उनके साथ जरूर शेयर करें अगर आप ऐसी
नॉलेजेबल वीडियोस मिस नहीं करना चाहते तो
सब्सक्राइब करने के बाद बेल का बटन दबाना
मत भूलिए आप कमेंट करके यह भी बता सकते
हैं कि हम नेक्स्ट वीडियो किस टॉपिक पर
चाहते हैं जल्दी हम आपसे दोबारा मिलेंगे
जय हिंद